La comunidad autónoma vasca en votos
con más de 30 000 votos de diferencia
sobre la segunda fuerza
y ha ganado también en escaños,
eso sí, igualado con la segunda fuerza.
Agradecemos la confianza de la sociedad vasca,
agradecemos vivamente el apoyo popular recibido
y sabemos que este apoyo tiene 1 claro mensaje
de avanzar y de mejorar
el del bienestar de vascos y vascas
con unos servicios públicos de calidad
y 1 autogobierno fuerte.
No vamos a defraudar esa confianza
y nos vamos a dejar la piel
en construir 1 convivencia sana
y en gobernar para todas y para todos.
Mañana mismo valoraremos
los resultados en el Euskadi buruachar
y asumimos desde ahora la responsabilidad
de liderar
el proceso de constituir las instituciones vascas
y nos pondremos
en contacto con el resto de formaciones políticas.
La sociedad ha optado por 1 gobierno Vasco
liderado por el partido nacionalista Vasco
y por 1 gobierno plural,
1 gobierno Vasco liderado por el partido nacionalista
Vasco y 1 gobierno plural.
Por lo tanto esa VA a ser
la orientación de nuestra propuesta.
Los resultados de esta noche lo van a permitir.
Tenemos 1 programa sólido y vamos a trabajar
para acordar 1 programa de gobierno.
Contamos con 1 experiencia y 1 trayectoria
que Han demostrado nuestra capacidad para acordar
y nuestro compromiso para cumplir.
Vamos a conformar 1 gobierno que dote Euskadi
de la estabilidad,
de la credibilidad y la confianza
que necesitamos para afrontar los retos
presentes y futuros de este país Comienzo